[Music]
it turns out everyone thinks you're a
superstar Danny once they heard you were
in town they came to us
stop
I don't think I could do this no no no
Daddy nope Danny trust yourself
I need to be nervous no reason to be
nervous
they're only Killers we've all seen you
handle killers before on the screen
fundamentally there's no difference what
do you think an agent does they act
no one expected a new day
new dad at best agents the Stars the
best actors are movie stars
I guess that's sort of true you're an
actor
as a private contractor
you possessed a unique set of skills
[Music]
you said it was clear I said the front
was clear
ah front back right wrong anyway shall
we I have another job for you so what we
got Greg Simmons the billionaire arms
dealer oh hello very serious faces up
here in there you can't catch this fish
with conventional lures I'm sorry The
Lure being Danny Francesco
the movie star Greg Simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's the guy very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you I'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law I actually love my
sister-in-law
you made that quite heaven when Marine
they're all the killers
you're an actor
with someone pinch me please is that
Danny Francesca what's next for you I'm
playing a mysterious self-made
billionaire he just described me shadow
me do whatever I do whatever I do to him
whoever Craig was buying from was
amongst you last night
I can get inside of them
I hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
what happened you recognized your Lawson
fortune that is a sexy name covers blown
what do I do the movie star's gonna melt
she stopped Ellie Francesca
you let me worry about that
what are you gonna do with that I'm
gonna shoot at them Daddy
oh
so you weren't seen by anyone yes that's
a yes you weren't seen by anyone yes or
yes you were seen by someone yes
[Music]
thank you